I've been to Oklahoma before I've never
been to Tulsa I've been enjoying myself
in Tulsa went to the outsider's house
Elijah I hung out at the outsider's
house let's talk about it
let's talk about it they said we're
going to take it to the outsiders Museum
pulled up and I was like where the
museum
[Applause]
and they were like it's right here where
this guy's smoking meth
across the street from the
from the book and I was like this is a
museum in Tulsa
and I'm gonna be honest Tulsa made me
feel good about myself
because if that's what you all consider
a museum I've lived in a few museums in
my life
I felt like I've lived in a few palaces
after I saw that I was like damn
I've lived in museums
Museum they said
there was marble in that [__]
anywhere
might have been a Marlboro but there
wasn't no goddamn marble in that mother
Salt Lake City I'm fired up to be back
it's been a minute but I'll be there
Friday October 27th and Saturday the
28th get your tickets now at
ryansickler.com
[Music]
[Applause]
funny show Ryan was absolutely
hysterical he's just so authentic love
the show Ryan it was fantastic love the
podcast love the Honeydew podcast so
good to see you live but I know I gotta
sign up for the patreon you sign up for
a year you get over a month free
oh